right so we are in the the mists of
Assam Pedro ceremony right now I Jessica
Ann and with Alan and Alfredo what's up
everyone we are in the botanical gardens
in the San Francisco's Golden Gate Park
we're in the Great Meadow right right in
the center right in the heart of it all
I think we're right in the heart of this
San Pedro yeah we thought it'd be fun to
kind of why do I feel like it's like a
riffing like freestyle like jazz solo
thing you know or it's like we just
started talking about stuff and then
yeah yeah
shout out to shout out to Jess and Steve
can we start where I wanted to start
earlier
just yes it's just you can sometimes it
can be tough to sit with the feeling of
duality and light and dark
well after one has helped identify it in
themselves done this objective of the
job at that as possible then one has to
be okay with the darkness they see in
the world and then as a someone that's
aiming to bring forth the light where
does one start because we were
discussing earlier one can start with
assisting some people on the streets
certain role for certain people one can
assist from some even higher sort of
trajectory guiding principles or value
systems what do you guys think
so what I'm feeling is that there's
there's honor and any cause that people
take you know that there's there is
equal value that there is not one that's
more important than the other or it's
all serving so by severing when you
serve all it's good so that looks cute
it's just like different different
colors of the same palette so you know
you have the artist palette and there's
different colors and each color is kind
of helping out a certain thing that it
feels called to you and what I feel I'm
called to is just a raising
consciousness that that's my cause yes
right so like awakening the hearts and
souls of others helping them remember
who they truly are why they're truly
here that is to me is what what my cause
is but it took me like recognizing that
I do not have to be helping people on
the streets of Calcutta you Teresa
mother Teresa style because that's not
why I'm here that's not my color of the
power my color the palette is to be
helping to raise consciousness and like
all this stuff but still honoring that
there are people who are going to feel
called to be a green or a purple or a
pink or a blue you know or turquoise or
whatever the shade of that palette is
and that there's honor in that
it's a massive color wheel it's a
massive color wheel and everyone plays
you know falls and you know hopefully
each person sees which color of that
color wheel speaks to them and resonates
for them and bring them the greatest joy
for it is in that joy that
the love amplifies and gets out so when
people feel bad for someone that's not
actually doing anything good when you
feel bad for somebody that's not helping
raise the world it's it's pointing out
and saying there's something broken in
you there's something wrong with you and
I see that and now I'm bringing
awareness to
but it's like what if instead is like
you see this person like how they are on
this journey I'm sending the love like
they they have all the resources all the
tools they need and they could always
reach out to the divine creator they can
always reach out to him and the people
that hear that call will come you made
that point earlier that looking at
everyone in whatever state they are in
in their journey is beautiful in its own
sense and that's totally okay des I have
I have a follow-up question quick is
just how do you live with the
understanding that every single color on
the color wheel has equal impact towards
light work how do I live how do you how
do you understand that every every color
on the color wheel has equal impact
towards light work when it can
because the dark the dark is all colors
right black is all colors so even in
that blackness it's a still a
combination of all the lights all the
colors everything contributes that makes
it black so isn't there a certain so
with the people that are closer to marco
in this analogy that you so beautifully
seated within us the ones that are
hearing marco and that are closer to
marco and that have been with marco
longer are they also not adding more
light and therefore we can say are
making more impact versus just saying
equalizing out everyone's
so Jesus talks about that he'll go find
that one sheep of the flock that's lost
even though there's the 99 that are
there and our paying attention he'll
still go and seek out the one so to me
in that same way if you're able to
change one person's life isn't that the
greatest light possible you know and is
that more or less important than
lighting up a billion people you know
like there's things they there's doing
doing that work and that that that that
goodness of bringing that out from
people what I like one of the things
that I got while I was in Panama City
was especially for people as light
workers this was really helpful for me
to like to get that when people get
triggered and their shits coming up and
then I feel it and then I'm reacting
because I'm like whoa like where is this
thing coming from like you know and then
and I'm I'm knocked off balance but it
was like what if instead if you
understood that that person's soul
recognized you as a light worker and is
crying out for you to help release that
which is in them that does not need to
be in there that's no longer certain so
that when you see them coming up in
their shadows and their triggers in
their anger and resentment it's to be
able to still hold love and forgiveness
for them because that is what their soul
is crying out for please love me please
accept that this is part of me so that
they can you know transmute that you
know that they can let that go that's
one of the newest things I'm playing
with so that helped me out a lot for me
I feel as I move forward that when
people's [ __ ] is coming up I'm like oh
that's not because of me they're
actually asking me to help him like let
that go does that make sense
so rather than being like this
instigator or something that's like
creating some lighter fluid
have them like show up and they're like
stuff that it is actually like their
soul is like please help me please help
me get this out of my body and it's like
okay how do you
how do you handle something like that
when you see someone's fear and resist
it or is it resistance and resentment
it's like that it's the absence of love
that's why that's there yeah so how can
I be loving to them even in that state
and know that that's what their soul is
actually asking for and whatever they
want to do with that you know that's
their thing you're also being discerning
though about where to allocate your
limited amount of time and energy and
with that discernment you are and you
are indicating though that some of your
love that you're sharing in light that
you're sharing is higher impact than
than other
because otherwise you would be doing any
of the light or love work but you're
choosing not to Azam as am i as is
alfredo well it just doesn't resonate
for us right
doesn't leave what weight has the
highest resonance right that's a good
way to put what has the highest
residence for you individually yeah okay
what lines of you high is what brings
you the most amount of joy so okay so I
would say that but do you know to your
point there are a lot of people I do not
want to work with like like that woman
that was mentioning that she kept being
a drama state I'm like you don't want to
be in this like this is your thing and
I'm for that
yeah there's someone for that that's not
that's not the kind of cold lab or
raters I want to work with yeah yeah the
code spirit for a tourism alfredo what
do you what do you think about all this
I think I love what came to mine is you
know thinking about a lot of people are
nowadays how they can get so you know
fixated on their everyday
responsibilities and kind of lose focus
you know what their essence is
essentially are and so what comes to
mind lies how can you
how can you what kind of space do you
need to create or what kind of
activities do you need uh can you
provide in which that would foster that
the abilities that that recognition to
recognize but then themselves what they
are and in relation to their everyday
reality mmm-hmm and and in the in this I
can touch upon what you mentioned
earlier about the duality of you know
good bad these lines white like darkness
and light and it's to me that I can see
that as a as an entry point of making
people feel more comfortable with their
own darkness and allowing them to
recognize it accept it and then see it
as a tool and in utilizing it
he said something there that I thought
was really important
besides that last part which was really
gold I loved that part
maybe they can be packaged together good
okay what if the experiences that are
then designed for people that are in
their everyday sort of routines are then
not only amplifying of their love in
their heart but also having them better
understand their darkness
yeah yeah and what would these
experiences be is the next question and
I was thinking about that when I was
laying down in my vibes for a bit and I
was just thinking about how lame a lot
of our experiences are like every day
like like how lame the just you you know
that one place on 6th Street next to our
studio that has the late-night food
available that we've dined at now where
we sat at sat at least three nights ago
or whatever four nights ago the proper
oh no no no the proper is fantastic the
one that the one that is a [ __ ] in
comparison to the proper okay you
remember the one where we had that slice
of pizza
oh yeah yeah okay so my so my point is
that the experience design of walking
into a two am sort of nasty-ass just
it's just bad it's just it's a bad
experience design whereas I was I was
envisioning what it would it be like to
walk in and have like this cellist
playing and then and then like somebody
grabs you by the hand and in like and
and twirls you around and you dance for
a bit and then there's like this
waterfall and animals that you can pet
and then you get served like a little
tiny dish of food and that like that
that is what I'm talking about woman
yeah we're we're lacking it then not in
not only that experience of
maybe a restaurant like that or a dining
experience like that but but just in how
would an experience like that maximize
ones love would that would that in that
design that we just made would that
maximize someone's love would it also
identify their darkness and help them
understand that I don't know if we would
help them identify their darkness but it
would definitely maximize their love
yeah I think so and but that's it that's
what you describe to me seem like
whoever to have something like that set
up would have to be designed by someone
with the intention to create a journey
for someone yes that is that was yes and
and and that's the that that made me
think like if that was the intent of a
lot of the people running businesses and
if they were given the resources where
they can flourish in that way then we
would all be just creating journeys for
each other
like connection it's like
interconnection right it's like
connecting with the chalice connecting
with the toiler connecting with the
animal connecting with the waterfall
connecting with the food it's like this
yes this connection theme like coming
back to what really matters you know in
that immersion of disconnection that we
all talk about so much you know they
came back into the the touch of it the
connection yeah
okay what would an experience that we
would design that would help people
understand their darkness look like
that's hard I know
it's why I don't know I have a review
that if you were talking this there's
some exercise that Sean was talking
about that the men do
he surround men's retreats it was pretty
cool I think honestly it's mirroring so
when someone says like I hate you like I
hate you
why did you say that why did you say
that how dare you how dare you like you
know just like mirroring like like
saying exactly the words and so then
like as it's coming up and mores coming
up you just keep reflecting you keep
reflecting you keep reflecting like what
they're saying mirroring it marrying
marrying it and so they're like you know
bringing it all out because I think oh
you think people would be have a
tendency to go towards darkness when
they're being mirrored like that
well they they're going to get triggered
right baby oh they get triggered yeah so
then it's like they're going into the
church so for me what happens for me is
I suppress so women tend to be
especially a suppressor anger as much as
feminism as brought out like but it's
like it's a leaked anger does that make
sense like it it's like leaking out it's
not clean yeah it's not a clean anger so
like a month ago I got super triggered
and I was like oh I could feel the anger
coming up and I was like all right I'm
gonna fill up a pot of water I'm gonna
submerge my head in it
my face I'm gonna scream into the water
it's pretty good so this is something
that I ralpher suggested that I do yeah
so you can still move the energy
Energy's still moving but it's like not
like just you know just being disruptive
you know in my way although I think
maybe it would be good for me to just
scream my head off as a woman just allow
my voice to be heard you know but like
alright so I I was screaming into the
water and as like angry and then
underneath it was rage and then rage
start coming up like all this traps
suppressed stuff they had there's a
screaming screaming and then I went up
to the shaman and he's like this big 60
year old Oklahoma man
and I was like Steve I want to
arm-wrestle you know he's like I haven't
I wrestle in 30 years I'm like I got
this I just thought this energy I need
just I need an outlet you know roughly
matching and so I would just like push
sounds like
I was like just putting all of it in and
then like you know when the next wave
came up I would push it next way push it
I think I did three times but then
underneath the anchor and underneath the
rage all of that underneath all that was
my divine masculine that I had really
tapped under and so then when that came
up then I was like like powerful and I
was like [ __ ] yeah I want everything
back that belongs to me I want all the
energy the you guys have had taken or I
gave you I want it back I want to know
about you and I just did this whole like
[ __ ] reclamation of my power and it
was amazing just to get it all back take
it all back so so there's something in
that being willing to face your fears
and you know all that stuff and Tony
Robbins there's a little bit of that too
it has unleashed a power within it is
how people go through what it feels like
to stay in stasis for like 3 years 5
years 10 years 20 years of stasis and
then he just has after you really tap
into how nasty of a feeling that feels
for you then you just shatter through it
and you
really go through this process of just
shattering through it
oh yeah I like that I think that you
listed the mere mirroring can trigger I
think so
I think another part of the mirroring
that could trigger people into darkness
is just the fact that the person that
they're sitting with us in this case not
socially intelligent because you expect
someone to be apathetic and asking you
questions and they're just sitting there
basically mocking you yeah exactly
there's some another technique that I've
been learning in my coaching program
that I'm in and it's about tapping into
your felt sense so what if we have these
little darkness experience designs like
you just walked in and someone would
immediately start mocking I know what
smell like rancid in there cuz you know
I'm seriously facing your fears really
facing your darkness yeah well the whole
rancid thing that people have now done
psychological Studies on people in areas
that smell rancid tend to feel more
conservative about their feelings that
at that moment so that that's just maybe
maybe that could maybe that could be
interesting to sort of stock up these
senses of a little bit of darkness a
little bit of rancid smell a little bit
of of annoying socials
repetition with people laughing too loud
next to the things dropping and falling
like so we're falling yeah and then you
just have to be so interesting I would
totally pay 20 40 60 bucks for that [ __ ]
because I'd be so fascinating to explore
what that would be like like how would
that unleash me how would that trigger
me so you saw the movie the game right
beliefs it's been a while oh my god
where he's like he's just like let on
this whole journey unlike his you know
he's like frantic he things you know
it's just toy it costs him like it
really really pushes him to the edge and
then he ends up deciding to commit
suicide he takes a leap off of a Ledge
to land on this thing but I was like all
plans like they had planned it all out
they knew how to get him psychologically
to the point of doing that of recreating
his father's death of coming suicide and
he he did that to be you know kinda like
reborn kind of thing that's pretty
intense that sound like that would be
like if before Alfred I walked in the
door we had already crafted the exact
path of of inputs that would enter his
being as he walked in through to have a
certain outcome at the
we you know you would get to that would
be that's a step beyond my paygrade
it's fascinating about the idea of just
confronting right it's like really
confronting your fears so for me that
was when I did a sweat lodge so I did
tennis golf and that was in US on Pedro
ceremony so I I drank this on Pedro we
burned down this huge bonfire down to
like dinosaur egg coals and then we went
into a sweat lodge have you guys done
that before I've been to bed fun us like
I like to be in photos for like an hour
and a half Wow so exactly I again there
for like five minutes I'm like okay
peace out like I can't breathe
yeah yeah not being debris there's a
huge fear of mine like mortal fear so
the sweat lodge is like kinda like a
smaller igloo and like you kind of you
crawl into it and so we were there was
like 13 of us in there and I get in and
I was like oh [ __ ] this is why I die
this is when I die that I'm the only
green guy was a bunch of Ecuadorian no
one knows where I am like I could
disappear a normal no like [ __ ] like I'm
[ __ ] like I'm in this sweat lodge
tonight I'm gonna die and so I got in
and and then they're bringing in the
coals and I just getting hotter and
hotter and hotter
they bring in the coals not that little
electric yeah yeah use like a rake thing
like they like shoot it it's really
interesting like that the K like the
opening and then there's like this brick
lave look remind me it's kind of like a
shaft like it felt like like the wood
shop II need some of these sweat lodges
in the city yeah like an actual coal
sweat lodge
it was so they were like scraping him
and scraping him in until it was just
like unbearably it was so hot and I was
like and then they throw the water on
and then they throw dust us on Pedro the
medicine in it so then the medicines and
the steam it's pretty cool he's like
speed up alumnos breathe deep and I was
like like on the ground and they're all
love like standing they were like there
everyone is swaying their asses off and
then they're finally reached a point
where I was like I had like my hand in
my arms like underneath the tent like oh
and it's not like being there for five
minutes we were in there for hours and
we did at least two rounds of like he
kept bringing in new coals and then like
more Sampedro dust and I'm just like
[ __ ] he's like breathing they would
get you in there for hours four hours
and then sure that was very cleansing I
yeah the whole point you know basically
you're rebirthing you're yeah you're
going through rebirth but there came a
point where I was like I can't do this
anymore and I like dope out and I was
like I made it I survived I lived it was
like starting to get light out and
although my god I made it through the
day and then the shamans son tossed a
bucket of water on me and doing me to
get back in oh that's so it secretes I
was like all right I still there doubt a
snake but
step out of queen this time I might I
[ __ ] choose whoever I choose to
[ __ ] live I just [ __ ] live and I
was like good yeah that's a lot of the
Robert this is I yeah it like it pushed
me I had to like transcend that totally
transcending and and I and I understood
it was a choice I could choose cuz I I
had this kind of thought in my head I'm
like oh you know when I get take when
god takes me he takes we're you know
when it's my time to go it's my time to
go and I thought it's like no you choose
when you die you choose when you die
that's pretty intense
you choose when you live and you choose
you can choose to win today but what
about when you get over come by a by a
tumor that presses against your amygdala
and it makes you commit suicide until
people that you love
is that really your choice at that point
well I think you would have to take into
account everything that led to get me
mad you got to work yeah so I had this
okay yeah you're right did you throw
yourself in that one point in time and
be like what now well I I but I do aim
to press excited I don't know exactly
how it how accurate that that is that's
beautiful statement that you get to
choose when you die but yeah yeah you
wanna you wanna counterfeit challenge it
whatever as possible so what if I'm born
with
with the defect that that I can't
breathe properly and I died after just a
couple days did I choose that or your
salted in my truth a my my understanding
your soul shows that everybody's holes
chose before they came here at the life
they were going to live whether they
were going to be a stillborn or they're
going to be 300 you know like they they
chose it they got all the characters
together your soul family everyone knows
like okay this is they're all gonna
choose this life okay cool you're gonna
help me with this awesome yeah and like
everything is done out of love even
though on earth it can be abuse you know
whatever it was it's like they all agree
to that part ok unpack this soul family
more what happens outside of them
outside of the realm that we live in
where I'm birthed from from the woman
into this world and then I what happened
prior to that what what is this soul
that you speak of that chose to enter my
body and what is the soul family that
decided all these experiences that I was
going to have that was doing a meld yeah
so there's a lot of you friend books to
talk about this so this is just an like
a amalgamation of different things
learned over the years but my
understanding is that in between our
lives or these worlds that we can live
in then we can exist in living on earth
is a very very challenging planet it's
why there's a lot of souls who are like
ready to go to the next level they'll
come to earth because what happens here
on earth is just so dramatic for them
there are many many worlds where they
can live in existences like like being
on a beach all day forever you know like
that can be their lives when Souls have
such traumatic experiences on earth
they'll go to other realms and spend a
couple lives as a dolphin or whatever
just to like kind of rejuvenate resource
renourish heal from what's happening on
earth is really challenging but for
those those are like for the true
warriors of what's possible from a soul
level you know we think about we're
trying to reach higher consciousness on
this level but our souls are even trying
to do that to reach back into the
infinite so that's that's my
understanding of it so then we have
these soil families that were part of
and I've changed soul families you know
as you go in your evolution you might
change out switch out but the soul
families are just this group of people
I've been beings
I haven't told about like 150 convene
your soul family baby and that's the
Dunbar number that's hilarious that you
said that the Dunbar number is the
approximate number of people that you
can keep inside of your social sphere as
a as a meat heart-pumping meat vehicle
human with your brain with a three-pound
brain with a billion with whatever a
hundred billion
connections neurons and connections or
even more connections but anyway that's
crazy they use post that you chose that
number because that is the dumb bar
number that's such a coincidence - what
the [ __ ] I wonder where that 50 people
maybe they are your whole family you
know and it's you know cuz yo me people
do that guy feel so deeply connected
like God I feel like they're like my eye
brother but just met them like how is
that possible it's like there's that
soul family recognition thing you know
happening
and then there's people who are partners
and that is people who are relatives
within that construct they're Schiff we
were just friends there's you know
there's who our enemy is you know like
you can be like God why can't I Glee get
rid of this person in my life like you
know the chances are maybe they're part
of your soul family and maybe there's a
contract that you haven't completed yet
so there's the slow failing then there's
also contracts that we have with others
to help them with a lesson for them to
get or for them to give us a lesson for
us to understand and when the contract
is complete then where these contracts
determined prior to entering their own
yeah imagine that you got to have to
come up with the coolest game where
you're like I do this all the time those
shows called simulation because I'd like
to tweet all these variables and see how
worlds evolved yeah so designing these
virtual worlds so you know the the book
series choose your own adventures right
growing up so those are like my favorite
but so what I would do is I would go to
the back and I'd read the ending I
wanted the story that I wanted so but
what's and I think though you know I
think a lot of us as human species we do
that we want to understand the outcome
like this is the desired outcome I want
so how can I reverse engineer it to get
to this outcome that I desire the thing
is is what I'm learning is that when I
can allow the divine to take over take
the wheel I'm in the car I'm letting
them take over it's like so much more
magical so much more amazing so much
more incredible than anything that I
could construct of my own human mind
what takes the yield the divine the
universe whatever you choose to believe
in and what does this what does that
feel like versus being I guess look
against that feeling of letting go so as
being in the flow right so it feels like
flow oh yeah so have you guys read like
I did this surrender experiment or
letting go Michael singer I think this
is named amazing book you would actually
really probably resonate with with it um
he incorporates meditation and stuff but
then he also built this humongous
software company was worth a billion
dollars you know but he still meditated
for like four hours every day in the
morning like wow they really committed
very impressive he would come up with
these commitments and he stayed through
them but then other things that's high
consciousness good for him
depressive so you know how it's like you
you want a certain outcome and like
things are just like stuck it's like
that you just hit this wall and hit this
wall and hit this wall hit this long
it's like I don't understand like why is
this not working when all those walls
are there for your growth well all those
walls could be or you're not in flow so
you're fighting against the current
you're trying to create a certain
outcome that isn't in the flash whole
flow of your soul what is what is a
divine plan for you so but when you get
in the flow you notice how things just
move so easily and like all sudden
people come in and like alright just
talked about this last week and you're
the person that can answer that for me
that's
like you know it's just like these
opportunities come up and like suddenly
were sitting on a lawn in San Francisco
in the heart of every slow and yes we
all agreed before we came here that
heard there's gonna be this moment as
high and where the three of us are going
get together and we're gonna be sitting
on this thing we'll be doing this thing
together it's gonna be really really
amazing we already you know so we
channeled that even before we met we
agreed to do it before we even met okay
in what and in the in-between and the
in-between damn trying to make this
in-between world relatable people my
favorite favorite things that I
challenge and it was that there is no
failing so there's people on this earth
they're like what if I die and I haven't
finished my mission yet what if I die
and I haven't complete what I'm here to
do it's not possible yeah is absolutely
cool impossible and the fact for people
to feel like that they could be a
failure and fail is merely a reflection
of their ego like the divine creator who
creates everything has contingency plans
all over the place so that there is no
way that you will not achieve the goal
and mission of why you're here
impossible you will not fail
so there's like that god is so hard to
package all together okay so so there is
a there there it there is an earth that
matters and on this earth that matters
there are the souls that we have that
are that are experimenting here on earth
in this place that matters and we
decided on what we were going to be
doing on earth because it's a harder
place to play and figure things out and
so we decided that in the in the
in-between and then the no matter what
happens
of the seven 1/2 billion people if I if
I die when I'm two days old because of a
birth defect or if I die when I'm twenty
seven or if I die when I'm 80 or
whatever period in between of however
much I will have achieved if I'm just
someone addicted to heroin or if I'm
someone that is impacting a billion
people that that is all what is meant to
happen it's all part of the plan
and then the question to that is that
that sounds very deterministic so we
determine these things in the in between
and then we entered so went it all be
determined then on earth so we live in a
world of free will and free choice right
so there is a divine plan and there's
free want free choice so you so you're
sunny you're trying to do you're trying
to get your pie and your whipped cream
your pie eat it but why would you get
your pie and not eat it yeah so true
what my understanding this is for me
this is my truth okay this is my
understanding is that we're gonna do
ever were meant to do here it's gonna
happen it might not be like you you may
not have been drawn to me or Alfredo you
guys might've been like gosh she's she's
a cool chick but there might have been
your friend that works with Michael
Pollan the one with the glasses who I I
did see he was breaking Mike margulies
yeah he was really drawn to me I know he
want to talk to me and there just didn't
happen but like let's say I had talked
to him instead and then we were able to
have a conversation and like it so would
have happened yeah so there's still a
free will and free choice and we still
have to be in agreement and you know
what - there is still free wolf which
was but how does it how do we back up
how would that let's say that you and I
are meant to meet right yeah and then
you're like you know the path on how it
happens might be different yeah but
let's just say you're like you know what
I'm not really feeling this trick I
don't
spend time with her but then down the
line something might have happened
because our souls agreed in the between
then we have supporting characters so
then someone will set like that Mike
would have said Mike would have stepped
in and been like no you have to meet
Jess and I'll be like oh yeah she
actually we met whatever month ago that
or maybe he would have stepped in to
take the role that you were supposed to
have because you chose you know fre well
state I know I agreed to this on this
other side but now that I'm here not
really into it so I'm gonna say no but
someone else will come in Oh fulfill
that fulfill that component that's
pretty intense so in between and in
between you can say that that you're
gonna have so you can't map everything
out in and answer then and so then even
if you choose to exert some free will
and not follow the sequence that you
were sort of agreed and then between
that something else would swoop in and
fulfill that so that the sequence would
happen yeah but then isn't everything
then so sure there is that a little bit
of free will and a little bit
determinism but doesn't then everything
in the long term on this planet that
matters isn't it determine then in the
long term that we'll figure out this
dualism and we'll get to a singularity
we'll get to this collective
consciousness if they choose to wake up
they might not choose to you've seen
enough people really like hello
like there's something so much bigger
and they're like I don't know I'm gonna
die and nothing's gonna happen I'm just
gonna be put into the ground I have no
soul it doesn't exist you know like and
so there is this there is this okay okay
so you're saying that it's still not
it's still malleable enough to wear the
unity consciousness might fit fail
absolutely singularity because because
we're in a dualistic planet so there is
always going to be that option of it not
working out now the divine creator
there's this book called the ascension
papers and this guy I was channeling
sounds familiar yeah he's like dad he
was channeling it and he was saying how
people basically this is a huge science
experiment but like all experiments they
have to come to an end every game has to
have an end and this is coming to the
end the divine careers like okay this
was really cool but we wanted want to be
you know happy moving on like let's
let's raise raise some consciousness so
I believe that's why we're waking up I
believe that's why there's spiritual
beings here I believe that's why people
are like oh we're their spiritual beings
here like there's like the it's like
okay we got to move this energy because
this dualistic lower vibration of third
dimension isn't going to get us to where
we need to be our earth is meant to be a
fifth dimension so that means we have to
raise the awareness raise the
consciousness raise the vibration that's
why the solar flares have been coming in
have been super super powerful these
solar flares have been happening is
because the Sun is sending us it's
raised to help lift up everything so
earth is already vibrating higher but
people aren't catching up so then it's
like we got to speed things up everyone
needs to be caught up on this earth
plane as it's moving on
that's my cellphone again in it has
still has the possibility of unity
consciousness singularity failing in the
dualistic world which I find to be very
interesting I'm happiest lies the
potential to fail does it's our earth is
the most one of the most I mean I don't
want to say demos I can't speak for a
banker but it's one of the most
important planets in the entire
existence of all that is so so but what
what troubles me about that is that
although that that seems to feel good
that earth matters versus the nihilistic
idea that or doesn't matter that there
seem could be other sort of rocks
orbiting stars that have had life
evolved on them that also matters but
that matters maybe less or more for free
will
we're free will they're pretty will we
are the planet that has free will on
here wait so the planets orbiting other
stars don't have free will from my
understanding Earth has free well we
have the option we have the choice we're
not connected to the divine other
species and beings are they understand
it they can some of them are darker and
they can choose to be like no thanks
you mean like birds and dolphins on this
planet and trees connected to the divine
like the Sun and no I mean like other
planets Oh like beings on other planets
oh they are connected to the divine and
they know it they know that they're
connected
unity consciousness they understand that
and then there's just different ways of
interpreting and there's some that deny
it or you know whatever it is but here
we forget we forget that we're connected
to the divine so that we're seeking or
searching or feeling this why is it that
we forget but that on other planets they
don't forget when their souls go from
the in-between state into that planet
because this is earth that's the
significance of this that's why the
that's why the Ascension and what you
can grow and accomplish on this earth is
so important you forget cuz you you
forgot forget about this so you're going
you free you forget you any conscious
you forget your being part of one of all
that is you forget that divine love and
so then you're like you know like just
feeling like that the heartache and the
grief and like you know all this stuff
we forget that we're part of something
so much greater that's my understanding
would you like this a it's adjusting if
that's the case you know if if you come
if you choose to come here to forget and
then intentionally I just think of like
it's a condition say try it on that is a
condition to be here under this earth
but the condition that you will forget
you're gonna forget who you are where
you're from where your purpose is we get
to come here and play the game and
everyone's gonna try to help awaken you
and remind you of who you are in this
game can you figure it out it just makes
me think that it the end result then
allows you to be something greater then
who you were when you went into it you
know talking about this made me think of
a something I read in hermetics
in which you discuss that as a being
here you this is put together through
you know from as he put it was like you
know the divine source and in all the
planets involved and allowing earth to
exist you know they all put something
into this
and in so being here on this earth you
literally have all these you have all
these components from all these majestic
sources and you are all of that in this
and so it's like it just to me that just
kind of helped put it into another
perspective of how gran we are and not
recognizing of it like because because
in all those other states it is majestic
as they are they're there there are only
that in that one specific state whereas
we can be in all of them step in and out
or someway be all of it all at once and
in that case there'd be something more
than all of that and so this is
fascinating we have access to everything
we are unlimited we are creators we can
create anything we
that's just something that was talking
about to Ellen it's like you have an
opportunity to create any kind of life
you want any kind of reality you can
choose to live in a reality of
limitation or you can choose live in any
kind of reality I just live in a reality
full of magic and possibilities and joy
because why not it you know that's gonna
make me you know insane and thank God I
feel like the the dreariness and the
despair and the melancholy because I've
lived that [ __ ] and guess why it's not
fulfilling well and I doesn't bring me
joy it doesn't help me bring joy to
others but when I'm choosing a living to
say a magic and possibility and joy
doesn't that ignited in others weren't
you guys drawn to me if I had been on
colic would you like that [ __ ] I don't
want that I don't want what she's got
you know when I was at the wedding there
were so many people can't smell what you
have like it work for it we were taught
maybe we should spend a little bit of
time talking about like what Alfredo and
I were talking about about just how we
feel from the medicine yeah just because
the last bit that we spent on talking
about this higher
conversation was just ridiculously
fascinating is so cool um yeah freighter
and I were talking and we were just
we're talking about how subtle San Pedro
is is just super subtle I guess if you
could describe it in one word it would
be subtle so it's like ice melting at a
very slow rate yeah very slowly yeah
like at one degree Celsius but it's nice
it's it puts you in fits you in the
state or I just feel I can just tell I'm
Way more receptive and susceptible to
everything around me and this the
sensitivity is like really it's just
fascinating just with a little bit of us
a little bit of sensitivity the
influence and
the impact things have on you and in the
especi like you know if you're not you
know stuck in a Mela colony food then
you would you would definitely be you
know receiving like what you talked
about what you were just saying earlier
all these wonderful things those just
hit much harder and just leave a better
impact and not more yeah yeah just
fascinating I like how he talked about
sensitivity because the times that I've
used psychedelics when you came over
here just and you said that that did you
discover what's hidden you see what was
hidden and that is a reoccurring theme I
told you that it's a reoccurring theme
from my psychedelic uses that I see
what's hidden and so where and I think
that that has to do with sensitivity it
has to do with subtlety that when you
lay down on the grass you might not
notice how the clouds passing by
overhead are actually in different
planes and how the ones that are closest
to you are moving at a certain speed in
a certain direction and the ones just
above them are moving at a different
speed in a different direction
yeah and that tiny subtlety gives you so
much more appreciation for Earth and for
life
for the watercycle ecosystem into system
yeah so subtle yet profound
yeah subtle yet profound and it's such a
short sort of it's only a short I guess
there's a short little kick that's it
there's never a kick it's that ice
melting but it's it's it melts good it
melts it's good but the it melts that's
that little kick that I'm talking about
that that melting over time is a little
kick but it's always but it feels so
small this is only the first time doing
it but like if this was actually only
four grams and what would it be like to
do 14 grams and like what would what
would that feel like how would that do
and there is a little bit of like
stomach queasiness that I still feel
right now and that I felt that when I
did LSD almost every single time I've
done LSD but five Meo DM T's [ __ ]
strapping yourself to a rocket if I
could find an exact opposite of San
Pedro it would be five Meo DMT they are
exact opposites
because even LSD and psilocybin sits
somewhere in the middle or depends on
your dosages of course